قيمه المواطن الافغاني يعيش في هذا المنزل
المتواضع بضواحي العاصمه كابول هذا البيت
المتهالك لا يقيه واسرته برد الشتاء
القارس ويعرض اطفاله للاصابه بامراض عديده
حيث يرقد حاليا احد اطفاله بالمستشفى بسبب
البروده الشديده
مشكلاته
فلا نستطيع تامين وسائل التدفئه من الحطب
والمدفئه مرض الاطفال واذهب بهم يوميا الى
المشافي
وزاره مكافحه الكوارث الطبيعيه التابعه
لحكومه طالبان فان حوالي اربعه اشخاص لقوا
حذفهم جراء البردي والفيضانات والتسمم
بالغاز وان 50 منزلا دمرت بالكامل كما هلك
سبعون الف راس من الماء الطرق
70 من المحافظات في غور بمركز المقاطعه
بالتزامني مع موجات البرد الشديد في
العديد من المقاطعه تفيد مؤسسات تقدم
خدمات صحيه عن زياده في امراض الجهاز
التنفسي وخاصه الالتهاب الرئوي والسعال
والاذن والحنجره بين الاطفال والبالغين
يسقط هؤلاء الضحايا نتيجه موجات البرد في
وقت يحذر مكتب تنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه
التابعه للامم المتحده من زياده غير
مسبوقه في الطقس البارد وان البروده ستصل
الى 35 درجه تحت الصفر في اجزاء مختلفه من
افغانستان نهايتها هذا الاسبوع عبد الله
هذه العربيه كابول